hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the penultimate
round of the 2019 feeder World Team
Championship it's Alexander leadership
of Russia versus Hans Deacon of Sweden
now Russia has been leading the this
tournament since the very beginning and
it's very impressive that they you know
just keep on gaining more points like I
said this is the penultimate round and
it's it's a very interesting game I'm
sure you're all gonna enjoy it
and I know what you're gonna say oh yeah
it's finally a game played by Alexander
Bishop now surely we're gonna get some
nice English took photos well you're not
as I don't have any from this round now
I know it's weird I always show them to
you when someone else is playing now I
don't have them but you know what it
what are you gonna do life is weird like
that sometimes so without further ado
let's check it out Greece who faces a
strongest Swedish Grandmaster who was a
five-time Swedish chess champion but he
also played the active football I don't
know if he still does but but it does
say on his video page that he he did
play it but ok I would add further ado
Gary shoe opens with E for with a 6 d 4
and D 5 and again I'm not just showing
this game because you know the French
defense was played nice to see 3 Bishop
to b4 we have the vinegar variation on
the board a 5 and now c5 this is all
very standard a3 attacking the bishop
now you could go back which is a really
funny line but here we have Bishop
captures B captures and now Queen to a5
just pressuring that c3 pawn at the base
of this very nice central pawn chain
push up the d2 blocking and now just
Queen to a4 as the bishop now block to
Queens control of the d4 pawn now the
Queen helps out with with an attack
against the pawn and here Grigio goes
for Queen to G for a standard maneuver
when playing against the French you
defend and attack at the same time very
useful and often if you well if you're a
beginner and you're considering and
playing the French you know just just
don't but if you if you still decide to
play the French then you will often have
to use the scheme to f8 move which is
the word black does here and it's
perfectly fine even though you will not
be able to Castle black black
we'll be safe there with h4 but it shook
a very useful move you know you wanna
well try to bust open the kingside as
soon as possible as the black king is
now on their fate regardless of him
being very safe there but also if for
example Knight to e7 to g6 is played you
can then keep the night just away with
with h5 and here we have Knight to c6 a
very nice move that well there is the
threat of Knight captures on e5 the pawn
will not be able to capture as there is
well this x-raying tension between the
two queens but the ratio doesn't mind he
plays h5 he's very well prepared and
although black can play Knight captures
on e5 here I really grand master Boris
of chinko 1 a very nice game in this
line but here black doesn't go for it
black well like I said it's a possible
move h6 as a possible move you know not
allowing White's to expand any for any
further on the Kings side but here we
have Queen captures on c2 and this idea
was never before attempted you know just
grabbing a pawn preparing Queen to e4
check with with trading Queens and ok I
agree should just place look to c1 the
queen is under attack we have Queen t4
check Queen captures pawn captures and
not just Knight to e2
defending the d4 pawn for the moment
black is up upon but it's a double D
pawn it's it's very unlikely that black
will be able to keep it so here F 5
immediately black really wouldn't mind
if he captures and on f6 Ambus on
followed by G captures where black would
be able to defend his e4 pawn of course
English oak is not interested in that
after f5 we have g4 just you know a nice
expansion on the King side also
preparing phone captures here we have 90
G to e7 and but even if black captured
the sorry for first playing the moved in
returning it
even if black captured it doesn't really
matter to white just what you want you
will recapture it black is stuck with a
now a doubled isolated epon so it would
just be you know a terrible position for
black so after g4 we have Knight G to e7
and now just G captures on f5 and here a
Grichuk is testing the cannon if he will
try to under both
responds by playing pawn captures here
but this would be very dangerous because
after Knight to f4 a white would already
be threatening East six and d5 which
would create two connected passports in
the center of the board which you know
it's basically winning for white and if
you try something like captures captures
and captures grabbing upon then rip to
c7 just gains insane activity for white
Bishop to b4 is coming you know what
some with some nice attacking ideas
Bishop to HTT race coming rook is coming
to g1 it will be just an overwhelming
position for for black to deal with and
he still has to well deal with all of
the development so we have Knight
captures on f5 Bishop to g2 Naugatuck is
ready to recapture d4 pawn we have h6
finally by black and now bushel
characters on e4 King to f7 preparing to
bring the rook into the game rook to g1
and now comes rope to d8 pressuring this
d4 pawn there was the possibility of
capturing and d4 as black is attacking
the d4 pawn twice but there's a problem
if you play C capture C captures and you
go after the pawn let's say Knight
captures you will capture with the
knight Knight captures then again you
face this very unpleasant rook to c7
check the pawns are controlling f6 and
g6 also the rook controls g6 and the
bishop so you do have to go back with
the King let's say King f8 if you want
to keep on defending your pawn but it
doesn't really help you but should be 4
checked and now you just run into some
very serious material loss or even if
you go to g8 you will suffer a very
quick checkmate
so not a possibility just yet so first
black improves we have looked the d8 now
attacking the d4 pawn once more but now
just Bishop captures on f5 with pawn
captures and now Bishop to e3 adding
another defender to the d4 pawn and well
preparing Knight to a4 were again denied
from f4 will have excellent control of
d6 squared this rook is coming to g6 not
a lot I can do to stop this so again a
much much preferred position for white
Bishop to e6 developing preparing to
bring the rook into the game but now
just nice to f4 and black doesn't want
to allow Knight captures Bishop so first
the Bishop to c4 and it's a nice
diagonal
to control with e six agree sugar does
not waste time this comes with check and
you can't capture it if you capture then
just captures captures and rook captures
and again your your you're gonna lose
this point you're gonna lose this pawn
black is just falling apart here
so after East six we have King to g8 by
black and getting out of check every now
improving the position also preparing to
bring the King deeper into the game King
aged seven King to f2 and now rook a to
c8 black finally brings his last
undeveloped rook into the game but it's
not it's not all that of an impressive
square for the rook for the moment so
glashütte just goes D characters on c5
seems like a counterintuitive move why
would you do this you know break up your
very strong center but this pawn here is
extremely solid the bishop from e3
controls it very nicely if you want to
remove your half - you'll have to play
b6 and lose two points for the price of
one
on the other hand it clear is the d4
square for this White's dark square
Bishop from there you will be able to
attack the g7 pawn and pressure it very
nicely so there are a lot of reasons to
do this rook to c7 by black preparing to
defend the g7 pawn also preparing to
stop any further advancement of D of the
pawn we have rook C to D one offering a
trade of rooks and now just a rook to e8
preparing the perhaps capture d6 pawn
rook to d6 black white take this
opportunity to put this rook on a very
nice d6 active square which is a dark
square so black will not be able to kick
the rook away with a light square bishop
and also well the knight isn't any
anywhere near keeping this rook away
you'll you'll have to go something like
97 to see it to try and kick it away but
you know white also has an opportunity
to play something so first we have rooks
e to e 7 now with a triple attack
against the pawn here and here a gray
ship just finds a very nice move he
plays Bishop to d4 not rook to g6
rook to g6 you get tonight c5 and you
you allow black some activity first he
goes bush up to d4 and now it's very
dangerous
well first you take away the e5 square
from the night
another thing you are very nicely
pressuring the g-seven pawn and here if
you want to keep on attacking these
exponent let's say you go something like
night here you attack the pawn then
comes Knight to g6 and now black has
problems not just problems black is lost
you can't move the rook if you move the
rook let's say here you run into well
just the rook captures on d8 and after
you recapture the rook rook captures you
get e 7 and then that's just it for
example you can go rook C to see it or
you could try blocking it but it will
not help you night f8 check now you have
to move the King or you have to give up
the roof doesn't really matter but let's
say you go King h8 or here and just here
Bishop captures or route captures if you
go there and well not not a lot of fun
bunch of default check you force the
King back and now look the g7 will be
checkmate so not really possible on the
other hand after this Knight to g6 move
if you play something like let's say
there's really not not all that much you
can do if you try rook captures which
seems like a reasonable idea again just
night check and now you will either have
to give up the exchange or you will just
face this rook captures with check King
h8 and now you run into well some very
unpleasant discoveries your wife can
either go for a nice windmill or just
rub the g6 check after King to h7 you
can go rook d7 check and now after rook
of 7 you will capture on d8 with check
and now you're threatening rope to h8
checkmate
not not much black can do here you can
give a couple of checks for example ok
to check now you you just have to move
King G 1 rupee 1 checking h2 rookie to
check and after King h3 there are no
more useful checks rook to h8 will be
checkmate so after this very nice Bishop
to d4 move by Grisha
Tekin and decided to capture the bishop
with Knight captures on d4 see captors
and d4 grip now on gg spawns and Bishop
captures on e6 finally black recaptures
that well past ecig spawn and equalizes
in material 5 points each but or grease
chick has a very nice move nice to g6
and the idea is similar
King is still stuck on h7 so night to f8
will be a threat in every variation now
you definitely lose the exchange because
whatever you do let's say you try rock
here it's just rock captures captures
and tonight f8 check will pick up the
rook if you don't do it after Knight to
g6 if you try something like rope to f7
doesn't really matter
look do you want first you attack the
bishop and now the bishop is attacked
twice and after Knight a rogue defends
it now you just repeated the same
variation captures captures captures
captures
and the knight will pick it up we'll be
leaving white up a whole night so after
Knight to g6 Deacon and decided to give
up the exchange with Bishop to f7
but now just Knight captures on e7 rook
captures on e7 and rook to e1 now rook
the c7 by black of course black doesn't
want to trade rooks that's pretty much
everything white once now we just want
to your up material you want to keep
training down as much as possible and
then you're just gonna win the game we
looked he 5 going after the f5 pawn
bishop captures rook captures and now
push it back to e8 here we have rook to
f8 pressuring the bishop
Bishop to b5 and now Grisha played ff4
and it was in this position and move 36
that Swedish Grandmaster Hans deacon and
resigned to the game so yeah that's
pretty much it you don't want to play
this position against Greece look
there's not really not all that much to
think about with white here you can just
move this rook and then push this point
to victory or you can well depending on
what what plays let's see who was rook 7
you can just push f5 and then after
something like rookie to check King f3
rook moves going after the pawn after
this rook moves it will there will be
very little black can do for example to
prevent checkmate on h8 so there there
are even threats like that let's say
check captures you can go to a four
again the threat of checkmate is here g5
check you can go here and you know you
will just very very quickly checkmate
the black ink sir after f4 to Canon
resign the game and again a swift
victory for Russia over Sweden and the
only draw was onboard one between
gondolas and and kurakin
all the other
words were won by by Russian players I
have the oops not that sorry forgot
where I put the standings yeah there we
have it
I just have to sorry about that
forgot to resize it but yeah there you
have it rocks are still in first place
after the penultimate round with 14
points and tomorrow we do have a clash
Russia vs. India but India will not be
able to catch up as you can only get two
match points per victory so yeah there
we have it it seems Russia Russia wins
before the final round even happened
which is a shame I was really hoping it
will be you know a really intense in the
final round between Russia and India for
the title but yeah India with 11 in
second place England also with 11 in
second place China in fourth place with
10 so China definitely still fighting
for fighting for the medal they had a
very rough start so it's very impressive
they were able to win their today's
match even without Dingley one onboard
one and tinglin didn't play the last
previous two games so he's resting up
for the final round it would seem then a
USA Iran Azerbaijan Kazakhstan Sweden
and Egypt with three points Egypt won
their first match so they would have it
with three points and also I mentioned
in my previous video that ali reza
furiosa won his previous two games maybe
even three and the half was actually
wrong he want his five five last games
in a row and then he now he drew one in
this round so apologies for that it
seems to be five games in a row
Jeff there we have it I do hope you
enjoyed that even though we haven't had
any extra Greek photos for this video
maybe for the next one I would like to
think Barry hurts Nicola bench Gilmore
Rowley David Ayer doll and Shaun Pitman
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it and I
just wanted to mention that haha
it's very funny that you you laughed at
me in the comments for someone trolling
me with a funny name in the contribution
but you know you also have to consider
that it's actually not a funny fake name
rather that it's a real name I mean it's
it could be a possibility I'm just
and on the other hand if someone decides
to make a contribution to this channel
while also making the viewers laugh I I
mean I really don't mind it's it's a
win-win situation so you know there's
that and also uh it's been quite some
time now since the this channel has grew
a lot we are almost nearing four hundred
thousand subscribers I would just like
to mention that for those of you who are
new to the channel who are new to chests
do check out the the first thing you
will see in the description below will
be a link to a famous Paul Morphy game
do check it out it's a Night at the
Opera if you haven't seen it quite quite
a lot of game you know I'm sure you're
gonna enjoy it so there we have it and
also I would like to mention the
subscribers video is finished I will be
uploading it either today or tomorrow so
you know be ready for that and the
subscribers tournament on leaches will
be starting on front on Friday at 6 p.m.
Central European Time so I will also you
know keep you up to date on my other
social media and in tomorrow's video and
such so yeah a few updates after the
game I do hope you enjoyed that as well
as usual you can check to my previous
videos your thing called for watching
and I will see you soon
as you know how it goes thank you all
and I will see you soon